comme un air de déjà vu ce samedi a
marqué la reprise des ronds-points
parler gilet jaune un peu partout en
france un an après les mesures
sanitaires drastiques prises par le
gouvernement pour endiguer l'épidémie de
covin
le gasc halak a augmenté d'électricité
car nos ventes et notre pouvoir d'achat
qui est de plus en plus affaibli donc je
pense que c'est une bonne une bonne
raison de ressortir en fait et
d'ailleurs on ressent pas on est resté
sauf que on a été plus discret en fait
on n'est jamais rentré c'est qu'il faut
que comprennent les gens on n'est jamais
rentré aujourd'hui on veut se
remobiliser et faire voir aux gens qu'on
est toujours là pour lutter contre de
tels symptômes augmentation l'état que
le carburant qui n'arrête pas le cas
mais à l'arrivée c'est d'avoir deux
cartons rouges en goguette ivres ils
peuvent nous rejoindre s'assurer qu'un
bénéfique parce que tout le monde est
concerné si les slogans sont restés les
mêmes en revanche la mobilisation n'a
pas semblé connaître l'engouement des
débuts dans certaines villes l'effet de
nombre est parfois venu de la
mobilisation contre le pass sanitaires
pour sa quatorzième semaine consécutive
pourtant dans le discours pas d'
amalgame possible et gilet jaune sont
bien là pour le pouvoir d'achat là on
voit que la tokyo demande le gaz le
carburant l'électricité enfin c'est tout
en x pire donc je pense que c'est là
qu'il faut descendre du coup j'étais
plus descendu depuis environ un an et là
je pense que là ça devrait repartir
j'espère que les gens les français vont
redescendre dans la rue il ya tout qui
augmente sauf les salaires donc
peut-être qu'il faudrait que le
gouvernement décide de faire quelque
chose je le montre dans son quotidien
est capable de voir et de constater les
augmentations continues
sur les produits de première nécessité
ce qu'on avait demandé on peut voir que
tout a augmenté
concernant les énergies augmente alors
pour vouloir à la proche de l'élection
présidentielle en avril prochain et
gilet jaune espère peser sur les
décisions sociales des prochaines
semaines et les mesures d'ores et déjà
annoncée par le gouvernement leur
paraissent bien faibles pour moi je
pense que c'est c'est que de la poudre
de perlimpinpin
en fait qu'on voit qui s'augmente eux
leur enveloppe pour leurs frais de
déplacements leurs frais de logement
alors que nous de notre côté on nous
baisse les apl et mêmes faits il gèle
des taxes huit mois avant les épreuves
une élection enfin franchement au bout
d'un moment faut arrêter de se moquer de
nous et je suis très très polis rendez
vous est déjà pris sur les ronds-points
dans les prochains jours